the Joe Rogan experience how about your
boy over in fight Saturday
dum-dum-dum fighting the [ __ ] rose
and strike is it's troit or stroke
strike strike yeah he's a banshee yeah
he's a beast he
Kayode under a lot I'm sure Lasky with
the left hook fade away left hook and
his last fight one punch series power
really nice guy - is he nice real nice I
can't weasel in DC but a cool name jar
Zeno Jardine rosin stroke God look at
him I would have to go to John - John
annek to see if I'm saying it right but
I'm pretty sure it's roses droid Rukh
Rosen strike six for 240 very nice
he's one of those guys will you look at
the other dunno leg reach thing now he's
one of those guys when you get a guy
who's you know I think he's 9 I know
that what it says now you know yeah I
mean you don't know yes we don't know
but this is a good tale ratio 88% and
he's a legit 260 plus you know he's a
legit giant you're [ __ ] crazy if you
don't think Rosen struck and Francis
we're gonna face off oh but I want to
see honestly I want to see Francis fight
in boxing I really do how dare you I
really do I really do you get a guy like
Wilder well not right away
I don't think that would be smart no I
think you two have a few boxing fights
but I think Francis could put people on
the moon that's a fact
you get some dude is not gonna take him
down they're just gonna stand in front
of him 280 plus pounds right now
yeah Fred's been lifting muscle dude
he's such a specimen he's such a freak
and I mean he's got a story that is
literally right out of a movie
he was a child working in the [ __ ]
sand mines digging sand that is score
that his shoulders that his legs that is
back that kind of strength training as a
young person doing that every day that
farmer strength [ __ ] that's for real man
for real you go against a farmer you
know it's up this exact but
san shoveling strength Mike top farmer
strength because farmers aren't always
doing that
sand all day long like diamonds and a
guy can take it to men
I love trick shot here's what they threw
out Francis to his office he got his
loss right lost a steep bay and then the
derrick Louis
whatever that fight was whatever I want
to race yeah but so he loses the steep a
he gets catapulted into the limelight
he's pretty cocky thinks he's gonna
start steep bay but then he learns from
his losses and you look where he's at
now oh [ __ ] this guy's gonna be champion
yeah similar thing happen with Darren
Tillman I went to see I saw the Junior
dos Santos fight in a pool hall I was
with some guys and we were playing pool
when we stopped and I said this one
won't last
oh yeah this is not gonna last Junior is
a great fighter but he's just his style
is the wrong style to stand in front of
that [ __ ] guy yeah also has some
Brazilian miles on them there's a he's a
shell of what he used to be let's be
honest so and yet the Francis is just on
this tier right now but here there's
sometimes you know there's losses that
happen for guys were you like oh man
like they needed those huge bumps and
they're in their career where it's gonna
make them it's gonna pay off in the end
I think it's happening with Francis has
happened with Darren till now as well I
don't know if Francis can immediately
beat top level boxers but I know that if
they put him against some guy who's like
journeyman who's gonna stand he'll start
to March guys and he'll start a bunch of
those guys
once those guys people get super excited
be talking about it I agree if they want
to do that but you're talking about a
different animal if you were to go in
there like the wild or a fury which is
almost ridiculous to say but that's
where Rack is Connor Deakins Floyd but
you know or even Moz but all talking
about oh I want to fight Canelo and they
asked Annelle can I go with the [ __ ]
wait time now but so but i am i think
with francis he if you put him in there
with a guy like Wilder or fury they've
seen big punchers before man he's not
gonna touch him there's just a different
level but I you might be if he's also
older so I don't know Fury is a perfect
example of a guy that's extremely hard
to hit he's so light on his feet he pops
that jab he's so well schooled one of
the things that I saw when I watched the
fight again was like um how well he was
slipping punch masterclass and
good by far the most skilled heavyweight
we've seen on how long and 6:9 insane so
tall it just pops that Jeff sees he
worked with till yes yes
till was like [ __ ] dude like and he's
like I want a real workout give me what
you guys would do until said he was
holding mitts and like holy [ __ ]
of course man and now imagine him with
four ounce gloves lighten your chin up
he's just too fast but it's whether or
not he would ever be able to stop like
steep a steak tower DC's takedown or any
real heavyweight wrestler dancers now no
boy was smashed I don't know why the
everyone wants to cross-pollinate you
stay there I think the guy who can have
the most success is Francis cuz I really
think that Francis before he gets to the
Elite levels he's gonna starch a lot of
people I don't know if he could punch
his heart as Wilder I don't know cuz
Wilders punch is crazy insane but so is
Francis if Francis hits anyone with that
left hook I don't give a [ __ ] if he's
wearing one of those cartoon gloves that
you get they weigh five pounds you know
those ones you get I know exactly Tommy
but here's the thing you know who ate
his punches steeping he did but steep a
moved away and use his wrestling he
still see big I [ __ ] rock you go by
so much that by ah [ __ ] steep a do
this it he went act all him amazing but
what how much different with that fight
be if it was just a boxing match that's
trouble if there was no takedowns at all
and he could settle in utilized amount
know maybe who knows maybe steepy with a
far different fight what do you think
steep ADC the rematch is that definitely
gonna happen they confirmed that I think
steep a my second crazy D pays got an
injury that he's dealing with that uh I
think a Mike [ __ ] crazies that
confirms our show to him I don't think
it's confirmed I think they're both
agreed to it but it hasn't been
confirmed it hasn't been signed dude
wait till John goes hold my [ __ ] beer
and comes up the heavyweight I've seen
what that man does the heavyweights in
training well you know the Johnnie
Walker thing was what was really
interesting right it was really
interesting to see if Johnny Walker
could make a big splash but then people
forgot how goddamn good Corey Anderson
is they forgot the MMA
about your hypo advancing into the cage
don't give a [ __ ] you knock a lot of
guys out they don't give a [ __ ] how good
are you right now and do you have a
solution to what Corey Anderson brings
to the table beats me he's a beast he's
a beast he's got an incredible work
ethic he doesn't get [ __ ] tired and
he gets better with every fight and
people forget you forget he gets better
but you got to watch daily Latifi fight
yep shut that guy down stops Johnny
Walker he's beating top level guys man
how about with TVs heavyweight now I
know and that crazy steep a Miocic wants
Tyson Fury super fight more than Daniel
Cormier trilogy of course he does yes
huge paid [ __ ] billion dollars he
also made it I'm mad a little bit
because DC made me wait for his rematch
so I'll make him wait too then oh wow
he's probably talking [ __ ] both you
fight - you're nuts hang on it is just
[ __ ] that make it happen I don't know
if that fight happens again I don't know
we'll talk I'll tell you what I know
yeah please do yeah it's just a matter
of time before John goes I I'm ready to
go and just [ __ ] everybody up well DC
John heavyweight dear God make it happen
oh my god what do you think about John
vs. Frances though every fight start
standing up man yeah that's terrifying
can John get in there fast enough dude
he's cutting weight to make 265
understand that oh I'm he said wait he's
cutting weight he's putting people on
another dimension oh yeah I'm just gonna
power punch it a hundred percent
however he ain't seen nothing like that
guy
no nothing when that guy kicks his leg
that guy comes storming in like a bat
out of hell
throwing punches that each one of them
has concussion written all over it
each one of them anything lands on
anybody and you're at 205 er I mean the
best 205 of all time
no doubt but if we saw John get left
hooked like the way we saw Gregor
Gillespie get head kicked and just
flatlined dumb Stinson shout out to
gloopy
I know and I was thinking that was a
really tough fight for Kevin ball for I
was like why would Kevin do this Kevin
look phenomenal well listen man
the
training with frost hobby and making
that move getting a real camp real
sparring partner game plan and a real
real maestro to like a master or you
have to have it you have to have it
today if you can compete against the
best and for us is just one of the best
ever
I told them that I've I'm like that's
the guy who trained the guy who you
fight like the most go there be that guy
yeah be there do that yeah move your ass
to coalesce Montrell yeah no black
people do that they speak French though
speak French they rap in French have you
ever heard French rapping oh yeah that's
all adorable GSP plays it in his car
well this is terrible could you please
switch the station
[Applause]